こんにちは　はいめしゃちょーです
服がありません
今日から実は２日間大阪に行ってくるんですけども
見てくれ
着る服が無いんだ
いやー深刻な問題だ
これは長袖だから嫌だ！
本当に洗濯しばらくしてなくて
一回服を全部洗濯しようという話になって
全部洗濯してるんですけどー
あの...量が多すぎて乾きませんでした
僕はどうしたら大阪でこの２日間過ごせるかって思ったんですけども
ふと思いついたわけです
服を買おうと
というわけで昨日に深夜に友達とドンキに行ったんですけども
あの僕は思ったわけですよ
このまま僕が普通に服をドンキで買っても
いつもと同じ服装になってしまう
それだと！
人生
おもんないやろ？おもんないんやで
あ、すいません　バカにしてるわけではありません
一緒にいた友達二人に服を買っていただきました
ありがとうございます
友達２人にコーディネートしてもらった服を
１日,２日目と着て
僕が普段着ないような服で大阪を楽しめればいいなと思っております
まだ中身見てないんですけど
１日目と２日目があります
こっちから着ましょう
どういうことだ
というわけでコイツが選んでくれた１日目の服装がこちらです
開けていきましょう
いやまじで緊張してる
俺これで本当に１日いますからね大阪で
あぁ＾～いいよいいよ靴下靴下
シンプルな靴下
おおおおおいいんじゃないすか？
シンプルなハーフパンツ
ギリギリを攻めるちょっとヌーディーなTシャツ
そして！
君に恋してるパンツ
これ待って　これ本当に多分YouTubeに消されるタイプのやつだ
ふんどしみたいになってます
ひとまず時間がないのでもう着替えます
お着替え中
やばい　はみ出してる
うわーキモイキモイキモイ
俺まじでこれで行くのか
ここから見る分には大丈夫なんですけども
後ろが完全にもうケツ丸出しです
なんでこんななんか内に秘めたるエロスをさ
内に秘めたるエロスをさ
こんなん着させるの...？
えーえーえー
ケツが　ケツがムズムズする
はいというわけでいかがでしょうか
初日はこんな服装で行きます
ドンキですからね
割となんかポイな～ポイポイ
普通に良いそうだね
はいというわけでこういう服装で
早速大阪行ってみたいと思います
超久しぶりに
昔コンビニでバイトしてた時の
上司の方に会いまして
すごい気まずい空気が流れました
やばいやばい　まじやばい
？？？：何これｗ
気合い入れていきましょう
？？？：気合いの入れ方違う人いるけどね
（それでは始めていきたいと思いまーす）
１日目ケツの違和感だけを感じて終了
大阪２日目でございます
案の定Tバックのケツの感じがすごい嫌で
インサイドですね
内に秘めた気持ち悪さがあって
すごい不快な１日になりました
では２日目です
今日も服無いからね
今日のコーディネートのメッセージはですね
という感じでございます　ありがといございます
頼むよー
本当に変なのだったら
今後使える服がね個人的にありがたいんですけど
素朴なベルト
ベルト
靴下
異様に短いショートパンツ
ピンクのシャツじゃーん
あーこれはやばいでしょ
本当にこれで行くの？
シャツよく見たらタンクトップやんけｗ
服がないからどうしようもないので着ますけどね
着ますけど
これはまじで悪意しかねーぜ
まじ行くからねこれで
イベント当日なのにすごいテンション下がったわ
イベント中はちゃんとイベント用の衣装があるので
それは別なんですけど
そこ行くまでの過程よ
ここだけ見ると女だね
まあ買っていただいたのはありがたいです
これで今日は大阪２日目行こうと思います
普通に嫌だな
Masuoさん：な、何その格好は
瀬戸さん：今日は何　Tバック脱いだの？
SEIKINさん：ロールアップしすぎでしょ
HIKAKINさん：なんかパチパチだねぇ
脱ぎたい
（悲しげな音楽）＾＾；
♪♪♪
wwwwwwwwwwww